the Apple watch is finally getting its
biggest redesign Ever After many years
of basically the same general curved
glass design that had slight tweaks with
the series 4 and the series 7 but now
we're finally getting something much
better and with the same $400 price tag
so let's jump right into my own custom
renders that I just had created by
shiles on Twitter based on all of the
leaks and rumors that we have today and
I'm also going to explain the reasoning
behind every part and why it just makes
sense for Apple's huge 10-year
anniversary redesign first of all Mark
griman recently leaked that the 2024
Apple watch will feature a new look
which obviously points to the regular
$400 model and no it's not this flat
Edge design which was thrown around for
a while but never ended up happening
probably because it just doesn't look
that sleek and luxurious so Apple has to
merge in a design that's similar to what
we have now being nice and Sleek but it
all also has to look just a little bit
different so here's what I came up with
let's start with this first image of a
silver Apple watch x which looks pretty
familiar doesn't it yep that's because
it's based on the new Apple watch Ultra
that came out last year with a really
unique design that nobody was expecting
at the time especially with the huge
crown and Crown guard that extends out
of the right side and the cool speaker
cutouts and action button on the left
side and a protruding top section which
fully envelops the new flat display my
take on the $400 series X is that it
should essentially take the best parts
of the expensive $800 Ultra but not all
of it as you'll see in the rest of my
renders so you can see that the crown is
a lot smaller than on the ultra and the
sides are now flat without that Crown
guard that sticks out the side and then
from this angle you can see that the
bottom basically remains unchanged other
than this series X text and that's to
keep the design similar and help save
money on Apple's part because I think
the sensors on the bottom are not going
to be changing and then of course you
can see the single speaker slot on the
left side and without the action button
because I think those cool unique design
features are going to be exclusively for
the higher priced Apple watch Ultra and
the series X is going to be a lot more
simple and here it is in the product red
finish looking beautiful and sleek and
the biggest change you'll notice is that
the display is now completely flat
borrowing that same protrusion that we
have on the ultra which I believe is the
best way to give it a flat display and
why flat well because it makes the
display glass thinner so it actually
leaves you with more internal space for
larger batteries and components which is
what Apple always wants but more
importantly the display glass is much
better protected from impacts compared
compared to the curved glass design for
example my wife's series 8 cracked the
first time she dropped it on a tile
floor within the first week while my
ultra is completely fine and protected
after multiple drops but with that said
I've got to admit something important
about my renders I've left probably the
coolest aspect of the new design out of
these renders because honestly I'm just
not sure how it's going to look or how
apple is going to play pull this off
what I mean is that last year in August
Mark Gman gave us a shocking leak saying
that the Apple watch x would have a
massive redesign to introduce a new band
system and more specifically the current
bands that we have now would no longer
be compatible because Apple would give
this new watch a new magnetic band
attachment system where you'll be able
to somehow attach them magnetically but
it'll also be strong enough to not come
off ACD accidentally and the crazy thing
is that we've actually been getting
multiple leaks that point to the
magnetic system coming this year
starting with Mark German's leak
mentioning a brand new look as well as
sleep apnea and blood pressure
monitoring so one point to make is that
if apple is truly changing the look why
not also change the band attachment
system at the same time for the 10th
anniversary of the Apple watch and then
we also had another leak from kasuami on
Twitter who said that the connectors on
the nextg Apple watch have been
completely redesigned so that old bands
will no longer work so because of how
complex this could be I left this aspect
out of the renders so I can leave it up
to your imagination in terms of how it
would look and how it would work but
with the new band system there are going
to be two major benefits from Apple's
point of view the first benefit is that
it'll save significant amounts of
internal space which means that Apple
can fit in a Lar larger battery for even
better battery life or they can
alternatively choose to make the overall
design thinner instead but the second
major benefit has actually been revealed
in Apple's patents their new magnetic
band system will also include electrical
contacts for transferring power and data
from the Apple watch to the brand new
custom band designs because yes Apple
will finally be introducing new bands
that can be packed with a variety of
different sensors
batteries designs and more so just
imagine the SMART connector pins on the
iPad Pro those same pins will be on each
side of the new band connections and if
you're wondering what's possible with
this well here's a hint the new blood
pressure monitoring system that Mark
Gman said was coming on the 2024 Apple
watch could actually rely on the new
electrical band system here's a patent
that Apple filed for that shows off a
brand new band that that has special
weaves and wiring inside of it allowing
it to tighten and contract around a
user's wrist which is something
currently required for accurate blood
pressure monitoring on those cuff
sleeves that people use on top of that
there are multiple bands that had custom
Health sensors built into the actual
bands themselves allowing the new watch
to support brand new health features
that wouldn't be possible any other way
like let's say blood glucose monitoring
and this right here is a genius idea
because Apple can separate the blood
glucose feature out of the watch itself
so they can keep the price the same but
then they can sell you an expensive $200
band that can noninvasively measure your
glucose levels at any moment and same
thing for the blood pressure band this
could be sold separately at a higher
price we also saw patents of bands with
built-in battery cells which would be
basically a battery life extender for
those who want to double their batter
life for hiking trips or whatever else
but now getting back to the design there
was one leaker who thinks that this band
system redesign isn't actually coming in
2024 at all M chaquil thinks the design
is going to be unchanged so with all
that said I guess that we have three
options right now number one is a full
redesign including the new band system
number two is just the design change on
the outside alone so essentially looking
exactly like all the renders that I made
with the flat display and protruding
metal ring to protect it which is just
enough of a redesign to look great and
then finally number three nothing
changes at all and we get another boring
update which in my opinion is not going
to happen because that's basically what
we got with the series 9 it only had an
updated display to be brighter and a new
chip and honestly I don't think it was
enough so I fully believe that some sort
of design change is needed for the 10th
anniversary Apple watch this year and I
think it makes sense for Apple to go all
out with this new magnetic band
attachment system so with that said
hopefully you enjoy this video as well
as my new custom renders you can
subscribe above for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next
video